hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and just as deku's
final Quirk was revealed and he looked
like he was about to defeat the final
villain the mha manga suddenly got a lot
darker as the tragic and brutal truth
about the hero Society was revealed I
did not think that Boku no hero would
ever get this dark or talk about such
uncomfortable topics but here we are
beneath the surface of the glitzy and
glamorous World of Heroes a horrible
truth has been hiding all along but now
in the final Arc it's all finally
bubbling up to the surface this is huge
for the world of mha so let's get into
it you guys know how this works leave a
quick like and comment right now to help
out with that YouTube algorithm and if
you haven't taken the time to subscribe
yet do me a quick favor and make this
the video that you subscribe and hit
that notification Bell to turn on all
notifications if you don't go through
the steps of subscribing hitting the
bell and then selecting the option that
says all you're still gonna miss a ton
of our videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how YouTube Works finally this
video will contain Boku hero manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned at the very end of
the previous chapter the action switched
from the Epic struggle between Deku and
shigaraki Sasha all for one to another
location and in this other location a
gigantified spinner was leading an army
of mutant Quirk users in a ruthless
assault on the heroes the goal of
spinner and his army is to liberate
kurogiri from police captivity and they
are presumably planning to use
kurogiri's Quirk to teleport
reinforcements up to the UA in order to
help shigaraki all for one or they're
planning to teleport shiraki Sasha all
for one away from the UA to liberate him
from that erasing Quirk while we all
know that all for one still has tricks
up his sleeve judging by the last two
chapters Deku clearly has the upper hand
and so shigaraki Sasha all for one may
need backup as soon as possible in order
to to survive I never thought I'd say
this but the outcome of the most
important battle in mha may actually
depend on spinner oh and we can't forget
that mutant type quirks are not affected
by Erasure so that is something that we
need to think about for the future the
latest chapter begins with some serious
World building we see a flashback that
emphasizes once more that people with
mutant type quirks that make their
appearance drastically different from
that of a typical human have faced a lot
of discrimination in the past and even
though it may appear on the surface that
the world has progressed to a point
where people with mutant quirks are
being treated equally there are still
those who believe that people with
mutant type quirks have tainted blood
and that they must be forced out of
human society by any means necessary we
are then taken back to the time that
Dobby's defeat was prematurely announced
to everyone on all the battlefields the
chapter narration confirms that kurogiri
is considered to be the high-end normal
closest to Perfection and so of for one
had an instructed spinner and his army
of supporters to attack a hospital where
he believes that kurogiri is being kept
in order to break him out of there now
this confirmation that kurogiri is the
most advanced high-end nomu happens very
quickly and the chapter just moves on
from that statement but we can't
underestimate just how important this
one piece of information is ever since
we first learned kurogiri's secret
identity back in like chapter 253 one
thing has always been bothering me if
kurogiri was a nomu who was created
decades ago by all for one anujiko then
why was he so much more intelligent and
so much more advanced than the latest
high-end nomu wouldn't the procedure for
creating a normal only get more advanced
over the course of so many years and yet
even though kurugiri was created over a
decade ago he seems to be far more
advanced than even the most advanced
high-ends that we see now I've always
speculated that kurogiri is so Advanced
because he was wasn't created from a
corpse like the other nomu I believe
that oboro shirakumo was still alive
when all for one and ujiko stole his
body although just barely after all
ujiko was a doctor at the time and he
was using the hospital morgue as his
private playground so he could have
easily made it seem like obero died when
he really hadn't and so for almost three
years now I've been saying that obero is
still alive inside of kurogiri and that
he will be able to return eventually
because he never really died his
personality was simply overwritten by
kurogiri's personality and I think that
this process is reversible this latest
confirmation that kurogiri is the most
advanced despite being the oldest
high-end maybe hinting that my theory is
correct and the fact that obero is still
alive will likely be revealed soon but
we'll have to wait and see anyway back
to the story spinner and the villains
who have been dispatched on the mission
to rescue who are also joined by
literally thousands of civilians these
are just regular people with mutant type
quirks who are sick of discrimination
and who chose to fight on the side of
spinner in fact spinner is leading an
army of roughly 15
000 people with mutant type quirks which
is just a massive massive amount of
individuals especially since they are
all armed with quirks there are only
about 200 Heroes and police officers
standing in the way of this huge Army
although to be fair most of the members
of this so-called Army are just regular
people not trained Fighters so a single
hero is able to take out a lot of them
as present Mike demonstrates when he
uses his Quirk to attack a bunch of them
at once but before present Mike can make
a decisive move multiple villains band
together and launch a coordinated attack
against him he finds himself in serious
danger but he is saved at the last
moment by Koji Koda who uses his Quirk
to command bunch of birds to carry
present Mike out of Harm's Way the
heroes and cops are doing their best to
hold off the huge mass of people trying
to break into the hospital but they are
greatly outnumbered and they are clearly
struggling even though most of these
villains are just civilians who don't
have fighting experience what's making
it harder to fight them is their
fanatical Devotion to spinner and his
cause now assuming that they are not
being controlled by some sort of Quirk
the reason why they are so fanatically
committed to spinner is because they
truly believe that he is the only one
representing them and fighting for them
against a society that has mistreated
them for Generations the people with
mutant type quirks have gone through
struggles that individuals who look
human simply cannot understand as we all
know in this world 20 of the population
is quirkless so they just look
completely human out of the 80 who have
quirks the majority have emitter and
transformation type quirks that either
maintain their human appearance and just
give them cool powers or that may alter
their appearance through transformation
but only temporarily and so the minority
of people who have mutant type quirks
and whose appearance is permanently
different from that of the average human
have faced a ton of discrimination and
even outright pogroms and massacres one
of the villain leaders from the
Paranormal Liberation Front jumps up on
a platform and tells all the mutant
Quirk users to let their rage consume
them and to hit back against this cruel
and unjust Society we then get a quick
history lesson in which we learned that
ever since quirks first appeared the
individuals with mutant type quirks that
made them look different from everyone
else were targeted for persecution not
only were they discriminated against but
they were even outright attacked and
killed and sometimes large numbers of
innocent people were massacred all at
once when the people doing these
terrible things were asked why they did
them they would just say things like
they were gross these attackers simply
did not see mutant type Quirk users as
real human beings and just because they
looked different they attacked them now
in the modern world the hero Society
wants people to believe that equality
has been achieved and that there are
people with mutant type quirks in
position of power and influence so for
example we have high ranking members of
the police force who may look like a dog
or a cat we have nezu as the principal
of UA and so on although I'm not even
sure why nezu was included here because
he's not really a human with a mutant
type Quirk he's actually an animal with
a high intelligence Quirk anyway
according to this villain leader while
the situation for those with mutant type
quirks may seem better now in big cities
where people are used to being around a
ton of diversity as soon as you get out
of the cities and into the country the
same prejudices against the mutant type
Quirk users still exist and all the
innocent people there are still facing
horrible discrimination all these Heroes
with mutant type quirks like Coda and
Shoji are just City Slickers who have no
idea what kind of hardships they would
have faced if they were in the
countryside to the villains these heroes
are traitors to their own kind and for
the villains there is no more room for
negotiation or concessions it is now
time for the oppressed to join spinner
and fight back against this society and
its lies spinner is their hero he will
lead them to True freedom
meanwhile spinner has no idea what these
guys are even talking about ever since
all for one gave him that
gigantification Quirk his mind has been
going blank and he hasn't really been
himself the only clear thought in his
head is the command he received to
rescue kurogiri and this really reminds
me of giganto Makia I wonder if all for
one is trying to turn spinner into
another Makia a completely subservient
and obedient machine of Destruction if
so then how ironic is it that all for
one has convinced spinner that his
mission is to liberate those who were
oppressed for being different meanwhile
all for one is out there just trying to
enslave him and speaking of all for
one's true intentions I didn't notice
this when I first read the chapter but
fellow YouTubers zoning pointed out in
one of his videos that one of the people
shown massacring the mutant type Quirk
users looks a lot like a younger all for
one at least from behind we can't see
his face so we don't know sure but if
all for one really was one of the people
who actually instigated the attacks on
those with mutant type quirks then him
now pretending to care about them and to
want to liberate them makes him even
more diabolical than I imagined him to
be that would just be so evil wow as the
huge and overpowered but mentally
disjointed spinner continues his mission
to find kurogiri he is suddenly attacked
by mezzo Shoji and his octoblow the
other villains call Shoji a traitor and
attack him but Shoji asks them what does
attacking a hospital have to do with
your cause back when the heroes invaded
the hospital at jakku they at least
evacuated everyone first but have these
guys even thought of doing that are they
really willing to kill a bunch of
innocent people in the name of their
cause a cause they claim is just and
righteous and it is at this moment that
we realize that the flashback from the
beginning of the chapter was actually
about OG I mean maybe you realize that
right away because of the hair but
personally I did not Shoji wasn't some
insulated City kid who never faced
hardships just the opposite he was
pelted with rocks and beaten and
screamed at because his blood was
allegedly tainted and inferior to the
blood of other humans and as he recalls
these tragic memories Shoji is able to
summon more strength and he then manages
to break away from the villains who had
been holding him down during the
struggle his face mask falls off and his
real face is finally revealed we also
see that he has multiple scars on his
face probably as a direct result of all
the oppression and abuse that he had
faced as a child and yet Shoji isn't
angry about the abuse that he suffered
he is angry that these villains who
claim to speak for him and who claim to
represent people like him are out here
preparing to storm a hospital and harm
countless innocent people for their
so-called cause joji proclaims that if
they intend to attack this hospital
without even evacuating the people
inside it he will never forgive them and
that is how this chapter ends even
though this chapter took us away from
the main battles and the main characters
I actually thought that it was a great
chapter it gave us some serious World
building and even though some of this
stuff was definitely hinted at before I
actually wish that it had been explored
more by this point in the story this is
clearly very important stuff that still
has serious consequences in the world of
mha and this type of discrimination
against people who just happen to look
different is clearly a direct parallel
to racism in our own world there is a
powerful message here and Shoji's
experience as someone who faced
oppression and then still decided to
become a hero is extremely interesting I
honestly wish that we got to see more of
this and learn more about him earlier on
because it's great stuff Shoji is
usually one of the characters you don't
really think too much much about in
class 1a and yet in reality he is so
interesting oh and I know that horikoshi
loves his Star Wars references but I
don't think that he needed to break our
immersion during such a serious chapter
by directly referencing Order 66 from
Star Wars it kind of put me off to be
honest not sure if anyone else felt this
way but despite the clearly questionable
Star Wars references this chapter
emphasized that mha has gotten a lot
darker over the past few years and the
story is now dealing with some very
serious issues including racism
oppression pogroms and even massacres
for a world like the hero Society to
feel real and lived in it needs to deal
with such serious issues and I am all
for it but still this is definitely a
very different tone from the one that we
had at the beginning of the story things
have gotten a lot darker and there are
very serious issues at stake here we
have to ask ourselves who are the real
heroes and who are the real villains we
have to ask ourselves how Society is
supposed to deal with things like racism
and oppression and we have to face the
fact that some people are willing to
commit horrible atrocities against
others for the stupidest and most
pointless reasons the heroes are
responsible for protecting everyone not
just the majority or those who look like
the majority of people and this is by no
means an easy task especially not in
places that are hidden away and far from
the Glamorous Spotlight of the hero
Society Deku has always been such an
optimist and such an idealist but it
looks like horikoshi is about to force
Deku to face some serious and dark stuff
and all of this could end up playing an
important part in the final battle I for
one fully support this because it is
important for deku's character to face
the dark side of the hero society and
the uncomfortable truths hidden behind
the surface and of course I look forward
to his character changing and growing as
a result of all of this did you guys
like this chapter as much as I did
despite the fact that it took us away
from the main battles do you think that
spinner will succeed in liberating
kurukiri and will that lead shigaraki
slash all for one to break free from
monoma's Erasure will my theory about
obero still being alive inside kurogiri
turn out to be true let me know what you
think down in the comments below if you
guys enjoyed this mha video and you want
to see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment it really helps me out
a lot and if you guys haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet remember that
subscribing is completely free and it is
a very real way of directly supporting
the channel you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
big thank you to all of our anime outpro
patrons for making videos like this one
possible special thank you to trucker
Tim a disciple of Lord twigo himself and
I can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons including Alpha Sigma Pate heffa
The Toasted Chi Cory McGowan own Taylor
and Anime s code M finally thank you to
all of our other patrons including Pro
Hero tier patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh on Hell Cruise Alicia actor
Fatboy games kaido might be a duck
alivenia Sandy and the school bus if you
enjoy our videos and you feel that they
provide value to you consider supporting
us on patreon or by becoming a channel
member as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see ya
Space Cowboys